the united states and germany has struck
a deal to resolve their dispute over the
nordstream 2
project washington has long been opposed
to the gas pipeline connecting russia to
germany
the biden administration has now agreed
to allow its completion without imposing
further sanctions though it remains
opposed to the project
it hasn't even been completed yet the
north stream
ii pipeline has been a major thorn in
the side of u.s
german relations the project will
provide a second pipeline under the
baltic sea
doubling the amount of gas russia can
supply directly to germany
the u.s fears that it'll give russia too
much power over european gas supplies
it also sees the new pipeline as a
security threat
as russia could shut down another
pipeline supplying ukraine and other
nations
we continue to oppose nordstrom 2
we continue to view it as a kremlin
geopolitical project whose
goal is to expand russia's influence
over europe's energy resources we
continue to believe it's a bad deal
for germany it's a bad deal for ukraine
the german chancellor has always framed
the project as a commercial venture
and has tried to deflect opposition from
allies
but she was also determined to resolve
the issue before she leaves office this
autumn
it was one of the topics she discussed
with u.s president joe biden last week
my view on north stream 2 has been
known for some time good friends can
disagree
and but by the time i became president
it was 90 completed and imposing
sanctions did not seem to make any sense
so now a compromise has been reached in
a joint statement washington agreed to
suspend all sanctions and tolerate the
new pipeline
germany in turn is committed to impose
sanctions on russia
if moscow uses the pipeline as a
political weapon
it also agreed to use its leverage to
help extend a gas deal
between russia and ukraine
but critics say the agreement doesn't go
far enough
and ukraine has already voiced its
discontent
the completion of nordstream 2 however
is now all but a
certainty with 98 of the pipeline built
it is set to go into operation later
this year
well for more let's bring in dws chief
political correspondent melinda crane
melinda is this deal a foreign policy
victory for chancellor mackel at the end
of her time in office
absolutely it is she has remained firmly
committed to this project
in the face of opposition not only from
several u.s presidents but also from
the u.s congress and even from some
members of her own
party she admits or she admitted
fairly recently that this project is
not only economic or energy related but
also
geopolitical but she actually sees
geopolitical
benefits in nordstream too she believes
that by keeping these
economic and commercial trade links
open germany and russia foster a degree
of interdependence
that ultimately keeps lines of
communication and diplomatic relations
open so the chancellor essentially has
gotten what she wants the project will
be completed there will not be any more
u.s
sanctions against participants in the
project and germany has made
moderate concessions at best
it will spend money but not a whole lot
of money
trying to help ukraine transform its
energy sector to reduce its
dependence on gas and fossil fuels and
it will
also agree to get tough on russia if
russia uses this new leverage coercively
against uh against ukraine but these are
pretty broad declarations of intention
and otherwise germany hasn't given up
all that much i think what we're seeing
is how very much the u.s wants germany
on its side
as it looks to get harder and tougher
with china
now germany has pledged to impose
sanctions on russia
if moscow uses the pipeline as leverage
against countries like
ukraine how realistic is that
that germany would impose those
sanctions perhaps even unilaterally
i think it's realistic enough germany
has imposed plenty of sanctions
against russia and and various actors in
russia over the past few years naturally
after russia annexed
crimea but also after the poisoning of
sergey skripal
and also in regard uh to the treatment
of alexey navalny the opposition leader
in russia
but the real question is how realistic
is it to think that any of that
will change russia's behavior certainly
we haven't seen much evidence
that russia responds to sanctions now
germany
will have a new chancellor after
september's elections melinda
chancellor mackel is no longer standing
how likely is it that the next
government will
change his position on nordstrom 2.
that depends on how strong the role of
the green party is
in the next government the green party's
chancellor candidate annalina baerbach
has made it very
clear that she would take a harder
stance
vis-a-vis both russia and china and the
greens are no fans of this pipeline
anyway because of course it's
transporting a fossil fuel and they want
to wean germany off
of fossil fuels should the greens be the
party that provides the next deputy
chancellor perhaps even foreign minister
possibly even chancellor look for some
changes on
nordstream 2. however it's worth noting
that in a recent survey
the majority of germans said that
they're for this project
melinda thank you so much good to see
you our chief political correspondent
melinda crane
you